[Music]
the secrets of dumbledore is more
straightforward than the last fantastic
beasts movie but this wizarding world
prequel series still has some sprawl
what really happened to ariana
dumbledore all those years ago we might
not get a clear-cut picture of precisely
what went down with albus and
aberforth's beloved sister however we
learned quite a bit more about what
happened during her death along with a
host of unpleasant implications in the
harry potter series albus dumbledore
avoids the topic of his fallen sister
like a severe case of dragon box yet
aberforth rebuffs albus attempts to
discuss their sister in the secrets of
dumbledore while the future headmaster
wants to keep their sister's memory
alive albus even opens up to newt and
theseus about the dreadful event saying
that he and aberforth foolishly drew
their wands without seeing their sister
come down the stairs one minute she was
there and the next she was gone to make
matters creepier grindelwald laughed as
the brothers dueled given the future
dictator's desire to get dumbledore to
leave with him the scene unfolding
implies a darker possibility could
grindelwald have let ariana die on
purpose another possibility is that
aberforth knows which spell killed his
sister possibly his own explaining his
continued grudge against all this and
his refusal to talk about ariana despite
the persistent whodunit aspect of it all
we do discover something else ariana was
an obscurial regardless of who ended her
life her fate was already sealed
there are quite a few new creatures in
the secrets of dumbledore but in typical
wizarding world fashion creatures that
may be new to viewers are typically
older than they seem the most
significant creature addition to the
third fantastic beast films is chilean a
magical chimera-like beast originating
in chinese korean and japanese folklore
however the idea to weave the creature's
presence into the film's high stakes
election isn't without historical
significance the real-life mythos
surrounding the chilean is precisely
what we see play out in the secrets of
dumbledore in chinese mythology the
birth of a chilean was said to mark the
birth or demise of a kind and just
leader while the gist remains the same
in the secrets of dumbledore the film
makes small tweaks to the folklore
instead of arriving near the birth of a
future leader wizarding world chileans
are born when a worthy leader is about
to rise up they mark a time of political
change and assist wizards in choosing a
new leader as newt explains she can see
into your soul if you're good and worthy
she'll see that but if you're cruel and
deceitful she'll sense that too in fact
the children's significance to chinese
history is so abundant that their
mythology extends to creating the
country's written language it makes
sense that the chilean would play a part
in the wizarding world's ancient ritual
of choosing a leader as the elections
have historically taken place in the
kingdom of bhutan a buddhist kingdom
located in the himalayas credence's
mysterious lineage has been one of the
most vital questions posed throughout
the fantastic beasts franchise who were
his parents what happened to them why
was he abandoned though we don't have
answers to all of these questions we now
know one thing credence aka aurelius is
aberforth dumbledore's son while
grindelwald reveals credence's genealogy
in the crimes of grindelwald the guy is
a wannabe dictator even at that point so
fans took grindelwald's assertions with
a grain of salt however both abraforth
and dumbledore confirmed credence's
status as a dumbledore in the third film
despite aberforth constantly criticizing
albus for wanting to leave with
grindelwald instead of looking after
ariana he basically abandoned his own
son credence is in clear communication
with aberforth at the start of the
secrets of dumbledore sending messages
in the mirror implying aberforth's
knowledge of precisely who his son is
even worse at the end of the film
credence asks did you ever think about
me to which aberforth says always so
let's get this straight aberforth knew
he had a son possibly since his birth
and didn't lift a wand to find him in a
sick twist of fate credence seems bound
to meet the same messy demise as ariana
all because aberforth failed to seek out
his son and train him to use magic
for a man who deeply enjoys criticizing
the actions of others he was pretty
negligent toward his own child
there's no way around it the chillin
bowing to dumbledore was fan service in
action the fact that the children
chooses dumbledore at all proves that
the wizarding world should definitely
use more than a magical creature to
select their next leader dumbledore has
repeatedly demonstrated that dominion
seduces him and that he shouldn't be in
a leadership position his quick refusal
of that power deserves kudos as he
acknowledges his own biggest flaw
correct three points to hufflepuff of
course the best part of dumbledore's
rejection scene comes when grindelwald
is visibly irritated with dumbledore for
refusing the chilean's offer to lead
it's pretty clear why these two were
exes at the end of the day vicenzia
santos seems to be the right call for
supreme mugwomb she keeps her composure
respects democracy and she honors all
life when grindelwald uses the cruciatus
curse on jacob she's the only one who
stands against him to end the spell her
willingness to do what's right despite
the crown's approval of grindelwald's
cruelty marks her bravery and leadership
one of the greatest uncertainties going
into the secrets of dumbledore hinged on
how exactly dumbledore and grindelwald
would face off against each other the
former lovers made a binding blood trot
to prevent such a thing and as we see at
the beginning of the film the blood
troth isn't playing around of course in
addition to being a hurdle both men have
to maneuver around the trot is also a
symbol of dumbledore and grindelwald's
devotion toward each other something
that still exists despite being on
opposite sides of the upcoming war until
this movie dumbledore has been resistant
to take a stand against grindelwald not
just because he can't but because he
doesn't want to when dumbledore and
grindelwald face off a heart appears in
the blood trough and the beating of two
hearts plays out over the sounds of
battle both wizards hesitate but the
damage is done and the vial breaks a
clear symbol of dumbledore's heart
breaking in the process when asked how
dumbledore could move against
grindelwald when the troth was still
intact the professor says he sought to
kill i sought to protect our spells met
let's call it fate but fate or not
dumbledore looks pretty miserable at the
prospect of having to defeat the man he
loved with or without you i'll burn down
their world
the secrets of dumbledore may be the
first time dumbledore and grindelwald
raise their wands against each other but
it won't be the last in one of the most
epic duels we've seen in the fantastic
beasts series thus far the one-time
partners accept their fate as enemies
albeit a little half-heartedly they can
only duel after grindelwald fires a
killing curse at vicenzia santos after
she wins the election or credence
inventions for failing him of course
dumbledore can't sit around and watch
his ex-lover kill someone so he takes a
stand locking the two in battle it's
important to note that neither wizard
casts a killing curse both men cast
reddish spells and there's no avada
cadaver green in sight not even after
the blood trot breaks so it seems as
though grindelwald's call for
dumbledore's death might have been a bit
premature and it's implied that gellert
doesn't want dumbledore dead sure he may
have enlisted credence to kill his uncle
still perhaps he knew all along that the
obscurial wasn't capable of cold-blooded
murder or even strong enough to take on
dumbledore in his deteriorating state
grindelwald noted earlier that
credence's pain is his power but pain or
not the guy can barely stand upright
either way in discarding the small
window he had to kill dumbledore himself
it looks like grindelwald might be more
capable of love and loyalty than fans
initially thought yet that doesn't take
away from the fact that he's a
cold-blooded murderous dictator
from the very first moment we see
queenie screen in the secrets of
dumbledore it's clear that she's
miserable for someone as whimsical and
kind-hearted as queenie hearing the
thoughts of grindelwald's vilest
followers had to be tortured for the
legilimens yet despite remaining in
grindelwald's flock her work for the
resistance is already well underway
though watching grindelwald slit the
children's throat maybe the witch's
final straw she was already well
underway in thwarting grindelwald's
quest for total control she admits to
credence that she doesn't tell
grindelwald everything she's clearly
credence's only ally in the mansion
which likely assists his own defection
from grindelwald when queenie sees jacob
again right before the election she's
insistent that she can't be saved and
that some mistakes are too big jacob
responds dumbledore says i have a full
heart but i always got room in there for
you
grindelwald goes from having some of the
most powerful wizards of his time at the
dark wizards disposal to standing
relatively alone in this quest for power
dictators rise through the ranks through
manipulation playing people's fears
against them and exploiting someone's
deepest desires so what does credence
want a family and how does grindelwald
secure his loyalty he uses his
loneliness plays off his abandonment
issues and paints the dumbledores in the
less than ideal light which granted
isn't entirely unfair as for queenie she
only joins grindelwald when he promises
her a better future for herself and
jacob
of course we know grindelwald's hatred
for muggles would never allow that which
he makes abundantly clear when he
tortures jacob with the cruciatus curse
however grindelwald's fatal flaw is that
he tries to take power far too
prematurely grindelwald was already
gaining hundreds of followers before he
attempts to win the election with his
murdered chilling in fact had he not
aimed to deceive every wizard in the
wizarding world he may have won the
election for supreme mugwump without
using the chilean yet he takes the easy
route which fractures the already
unstable loyalty of his followers when
his devious plot unravels grindelwald's
premature self-sabotage puts him in a
unique position that we haven't yet seen
from a wizarding world villain he's
standing alone sure his support isn't
wholly diminished but he's lost his most
powerful supporters and he has to start
from square one in his quest for
domination
one of the most goosebumps inducing
lines from the original series comes
when harry says even though we've got a
fight ahead of us we've got one thing
that voldemort doesn't have something
worth fighting for if there's one thing
that the harry potter series drilled
into fans heads it's that love is the
most extraordinary power after all
lily's love for her son is so tangible
that it leaves him with magical
protection long after she's gone given
that both franchises depict a dictator's
rise both fans and characters need a
reminder of what exactly they're
fighting for grindelwald has just used
the cruciatus curse on jacob he's just
declared war on the muggles he goes on a
tirade calling muggles vermin who
dilutes the wizarding bloodline yet
despite all of that hateful rhetoric and
the odds stacked against queenie and
jacob is the muggle witch pairing they
throw all of that drama aside choosing
each other sure the wedding is cute and
sweet and provides another will they
won't they moment for tina and newt but
all that aside this wedding is a
statement that grindelwald's threats
will not cow them and they know exactly
what they're fighting for on the flip
side grindelwald has forsaken love for
war and power which is the greatest
tragedy of all and a waste of a powerful
man who could do so much good in the
world had he chosen a different path
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos but
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
you